hi there how is everyone doing
today we'll look at the perceiver
general perception with
iterative attention by andrew yeagel
felix giamino
andrew brock andrew scissorman oriol
vigneals and
zhao carrera of deep mind this
paper on a high level describes a model
called the
perceiver and what this model does
is it interleaves a latent
self-attention mechanism with
cross-attention mechanism and so it is a
transformer
and the secret is that the data only
enters
the transformer through this
cross-attention mechanism that allows
the model to have
the latent array be of significantly
lower size
than the data array and this solves in
part
the transformers quadratic bot memory
and
compute bottleneck the
image comes in or the data rather
comes in multiple times through this
stack and the weights
can be shared making it essentially a
recurrent neural network
this model here works for
any modality so the paper not only does
images
but videos and audio and point clouds
and you almost have to you have to
change pretty much
nothing about the input in order for the
model to work
so this is a pretty big step towards
first of all making transformers more
deep
and second of all applying the same
models
to very very different modalities of
data so we'll dive into the paper we'll
look at how it's done
it's actually a fairly simple idea
so shouldn't take us too long i always
say that but
maybe today we'll achieve it if you like
content like this
yeah tell me how you feel in the
comments leave a like
tell your friends about it and let's go
so they motivate the name the name
perceiver
it's it's not really tied to anything
they mo they motivated by saying
biological systems
understand the world by simultaneously
processing
high dimensional inputs from modalities
as diverse as vision
audition touch proprioception etc
the perception models used in deep
learning on the other hand
are designed for individual modalities
often relying on those domain specific
assumptions
such as the local grid structures
exploited by virtually all
existing vision models so what do they
mean
they mean if we have an image and the
image is of
a not a cat a house what did you think
so the image is of a house and
if we have an image processing pipeline
usually what it will do
it is it will assume that the image is
some sort of grid
and that you can localize any pixel by
its xy
coordinate and also that the pixel
is in some kind of relation to the pixel
around it
you usually build models according to
that so
a convolutional neural network very
explicitly
will slide over a filter over the image
with all shared weights and therefore it
directly says that
what matters to a pixel is the pixels
around it
and only in the upper layers and after
some pooling
do these receptive fields grow such that
more and more information across larger
distances is incorporated
on the other hand something like a
visual transformer like the vit
what it will do is it will do
transformer like attention but
because it can't because the images are
so large because whatever 224 by 224
pixels
are just too much to put into one
transformer
it will simply subdivide the image into
these patches and therefore it also
essentially says it will take
each patch and make a vector out of it
so it also essentially says that
whatever pixels are close together they
go into this
one vector so they're treated as
a group so this this paper says that all
the current architectures that deal with
computer vision
somehow have this built in
however the the
so so other models have that too other
modalities like audio video and so on
and the perceiver here is supposed to
alleviate that so they say it induces
helpful inductive biases but also
lock models to individual modalities in
this paper we introduce the perceiver
a model that builds upon transformers
and hence makes few architecture makes
few architectural assumptions
about the relationship between its
inputs but also scales to hundreds of
thousands of inputs like convnets
so transformers uh notably
have our models that transform sequences
to sequences or let's say
sets to sets so you have an input set
and
what we've usually come to know as
transformers are stacks
of self-attention layers and in the
self-attention layer
what you would do is you would simply
transform the input
into an equally length output sequence
and in the middle you'd have this
attention mechanism
and the attention mechanism essentially
needs to compute the weight between
every one of the inputs and every one of
the outputs
giving rise to an o of
let's call that m i think they call it m
squared
so here you have m sequence length so an
o of m
squared compute and memory requirements
now if m is small that's not a problem
but if we go into the range of nlp
usually so in
in nlp we usually deal with m's
in the order of i don't know 2000
1000 let's say 1000
so in the order of 1000 though we would
want
more ideally but in the in the computer
vision
our m is easily something like 50k
which is about 224 squared
so the m squared would be 50 000
squared and that just blows the memory
of our computers
um maybe not the ones in the future but
certainly the ones now
all right so the problem here
is that these transformer architectures
take too much memory
what this paper does is it goes ahead
and it says
couldn't we do a better job so
usually in a transformer layer i'm gonna
draw this again here
as two layers what you'll do is you'll
compute
queries keys and values from the
same input so you have your input
right here and what you'll do is you'll
compute queries
keys and values from that input and
those
get mingled together in the attention
and that gives you the next layer and
you'll produce queries
keys and values again queries
especially are of size m by d
keys are also of size m by
d now if you multiply those two together
and you transpose this you can clearly
see that gives you
m a matrix of size m by
m what this paper does is it
it says okay um we can draw back
actually on
what the very initial transformers
proposed
the very initial transformers if you
remember
and if you don't you can go watch my
video on it
the very initial transformers were
something like generative
models that had an input sequence
and they had an output sequence so the
output sequence and maybe that wasn't
fully completed yet right so you want to
predict the next thing but there was a
clear distinction
between sequence a and sequence
b now sequence b would do
self-attention so they would have these
stacks of self-attention layers with the
quadratic thing and ultimately
you'd want some kind of output here such
that you know
what the next word would be this isn't
so sort of an auto-regressive model
however the input uh did not use
self-attention it used
cross attention so it it was also a
stack but it
used cross attention so it went
like sort of like this over um
and the way that works is so by the way
think of machine translation right
so here is the german sentence and here
is the half
finished english sentence that you would
want to complete so
if you want to know what's here you need
to attend
to the english sentence
so every part of the english sentence
needs to attend to the english sentence
but also every part of the english
sentence needs to attend to the german
sentence that's why you have these paths
going over
but none of the german sentence
necessarily needs to attend to the
english sentence
it could make sense but it's you know
it's a
restriction where you say okay the
information flows from the german
sentence to the english sentence
so and that results in this cross
attention
where the keys and the values are
produced
from send like sequence a but the
queries to do the cross
attention so the queries for this
particular flow of information
are produced by the target sentence and
you'll notice something
these now can be of different lengths
notably if the sentence b
right now is much shorter than the
sentence a
that would result in a shorter q and
that would result
not in an m by m here but that would
result
in like an m by something
smaller right and let's call this
n and if n is much smaller than m
then you don't have this quadratic
bottleneck
so that's exactly what this model does
essentially
let me just get rid of all of this stuff
again
this is akin to a few things so it's
akin to the original transformers it's
also akin
to if you remember the model
d e t r which is a detection model
and what we call the things there
are learned queries so what do we do
here
we start with our goal is to be
to have a latent array that is not huge
so n here is a size that we can handle
in a regular transformer
and this stack the top row
here is just a regular self-attention
transformer
with all the drawbacks but because we
only have
a q of we only have sequences of length
n
the self-attention modules right here so
this is
latent transformer this is classic
self-attention that we do
here and here and you know in all the
stacks in all the
layers to follow but we can handle it
because n
is relatively small so in this paper i
think n
is something like 500 or a 1000
it's something you can handle with
current hardware the problem is
when you when you know you want to bring
in an
image but this is quite smart
what do they do they take the image
and they just unroll it into a byte
array so
now we have the m here and the m is huge
the m is 50
000. however because we produce the
queries
from the latent array and not from the
image itself
um we won't get the quadratic blow up
so this is m and this is n and you can
see that results in an
n by m a tension matrix and not an m
by m attention matrix so in this cross
attention module the data of the image
comes in to the latent uh into the
transformer
however it is not transformed into an
equally long sequence it is transformed
into a much shorter sequence
namely this latent state on this latent
state we have a transformer transforming
it into a new latent state
from that queries are generated to do
cross attention
again to the same image so the same
image will come in
every single layer the same image will
come in
to the into the architecture
and so on so if this reminds you of a
recurrent neural network that
it is sort of a recurrent neural network
especially because they say you can also
share these weights between repeats if
you share these weights
it is definitely a recurrent neural
network where this here is the initial
state which you either learn or randomly
initialize in this case i'm pretty sure
this is learned though i might have
misread so this concept
again it relates to rnns in fact it is
an rnn if you share the weights
it relates to learned queries
as opposed to generated queries so you
can learn the queries
instead of generating them when you
learn them you can choose yourself
how many there are and it also sort of
relates to i'm not sure but
how to call this you can see the image
goes in multiple times
so the way conceptually you can think of
this is that
here is a bunch of learned queries they
have no clue about the incoming data
so what you generate here is just kind
of a generic set of queries
um like what would you know what would
you like to know about this incoming
data point
and you have a thousand things that you
can want to know
and you have i don't know 50 000 things
to attend to
so you're going to choose a thousand
criteria right to to gather from that
input data
now the way attention works right is the
queries you have a set of queries q
and you have a set of keys down here
a bunch of keys more than queries and
every query exposes sort of a vector
and every key exposes a vector
and the information is routed by means
of
highest or high inner product so you
would
route things that have a high inner
product together like these two
um yeah those are the ones that you
would write
so every key potentially has a
not potentially every key has a vector
associated with it
so the queries essentially say what kind
of things
i would like to know of the incoming
data
and the keys are say for each pixel in
the data say
what kind of things that particular
pixel
offers to to the to the um
to the model if you just do this once
you
might get some generic information but
then you get to do it again
and you will notice that the queries
here the later queries
are a result of that processing
so the data comes through through here
right and influences these next queries
therefore these next queries here can be
dependent on the earlier data so
you can pretty easily see that you know
now the next time you're going to attend
to this data
you do this in an informed fashion you
already
kind of know what's in there so you
refine what you would like to know
about the data and so on you can refine
and refine you can ask
for more and more specific things the
more you learn about the data
so this is really a process of learning
more and more about the data in a
dynamic way where
you can say what you would like to know
and
you know this uh i i think it's a it's a
great idea
it might be refined in the future but it
certainly does um
also you know it makes sense and it also
solves the uh kind of quadratic
bottleneck oh
wait i almost forgot i had a visual
demonstration of how
the quadratic bottleneck here is solved
bear with me
here's a matrix it's m by m now watch
[Music]
problem solved all right
so by the way that the lower is supposed
to represent
n by m i did not write that down
okay so this not only allows you to
overcome this quadratic bottleneck it
also allows you to build
much deeper transformers so i believe
their best architecture here
had 40 sorry 48
layers of transformer which you know we
can do
in in kind of nlp but it takes a lot of
hardware
and when they also share the weights
their
number of parameters in these things is
not more i think it's comparable to kind
of a
a resnet a standard resnet
so yeah pretty cool
there is so they apply this to pictures
they apply this to videos they apply
this to audio they apply it to video and
audio
together they apply to 3d point clouds
though one has to say for video they
don't actually put the entire video
into so that this here isn't the entire
video
but they i think they also put kind of
little
um time space chunks of the video in it
so it doesn't solve
yet all the problems with transformers
it's still
if a data point is huge you won't get it
in there uh simply by the fact that is
linearly huge
what you will solve is the fact that
things are quadratically
huge the last thing to do
is um to pay attention to this thing
positional encodings now the way they do
positional
encodings is as so now we have like a
fully
fully independent like a data modality
independent architecture right it's it's
important to realize this
this thing here has nothing to do with
an image like is it an image
who knows right we don't care we simply
this is the array of pixels this is
simply the unrolled
the unrolled image um there is no
convolutional filter there's no
patching or batching or anything it's
just the image or
it's the audio data right it's like
sample after sample of
audio data and so on this um
you can even think of a situation where
you would feed in
different parts of the data from time
step to time step in which case it
really becomes like
a a recurrent just like a recurrent
neural network
um but the point is the
transformers they are invariant
to to position so if
i feed one two three four five into a
transformer
it will do exactly the same thing as if
i feed
three one two four five
that is not much of a permutation but it
is so it is
it is invariant now that is that that's
stifles it because we you know there is
something
to something being in a certain location
right
especially if you think of text um word
order matters and so on
what we so but there's a clear
distinction we don't want to build
these things into the architecture but
we want to give the model
the possibility to exploit that
information because
clearly it's there like a piece of text
is not just a set
it is an actual um string
of ordered words so what do we do
we give positional encodings with the
input and position encodings
you know have been used all over the
place transformers
specifically need them the way this
paper does transit
does positional encodings is like they
do it or much like they do it in the
first transformer paper and that is by
fourier features so if you have five
inputs right here
you build up kind of a fourier bank of
of
frequencies um so this is the lowest
frequency
something like this like a sine wave and
then a higher frequency
well five probably wasn't the optimal
thing to demonstrate this
um so by kind of
indexing so here if we look at the
position number two right here
um it has like
if we just consider this binary it has
like no not binary like
0.9.9
minus 1. that's kind of the encoding
that's the positional encoding of that
location
and if we look at three it's 0.9
minus one one
um so you can see that you can
with this kind of positional encoding as
opposed to a learned positional encoding
what you can do is you can always detect
when two things
are close together that means that in
the lower frequencies they will
share the same number and
you can but you can also do very high
resolution you go to the highest
frequencies and if they're different
there
but if they match all of the frequencies
above them
that means they're like right next to
each other so that's how you do
position encoding with fourier features
again i discussed this at length in my
attention is all you need
video the fourier features also have the
additional
benefit that you don't rely on learned
encodings which means you don't
you don't rely on the fact that
you have kind of an exact or a maximum
amount of sequence length
so the yeah i mean you still have kind
of a maximum here
but i like this more because it's
sort of independent it's one less thing
to learn
and the learning happens in the
processing itself
so in terms of experiments it's pretty
simple they are in vision
they are on par with something like
a resnet 50 and uh
they're you know they're doing pretty
well in vision without
any sort of assumption that the input
data is an image
right that's the that's the crazy part
so other than the position encodings
which are the the fourier features in
two dimensions
um there is nothing here saying this is
an image it's simply a
array of pixels this it
i think that's crazy um
and sorry
this is a visualization of the attention
maps
so in this model specifically what they
do is
layer one has a set of weights then
layers two
two i think seven have as a different
set of weights
and then layer eight has another set of
weights so layer one is
the blue here layer two to seven
share the weights they're green and the
last layer i don't have do i have orange
here okay
and you can see that these are the
attention maps of different channels
and they stress that they don't overlay
it on the image so the attention map in
the first
layer actually really attends
to the image pixels you can see the dog
clearly in many many of these
uh attention maps right here like where
it attends to
clearly attends to parts of the of the
dog
and it seems that it can do sort of
edge no it kind of attends to
the intensity of the pixels right in the
first layer
then in this second to to seventh layer
attention maps look like this so they
look like sort of a grid
so they heavily rely on these positional
encodings
in order to build up this grid however
this grid is not always the same
it's sort of different for different
things and then in the last layer again
my question would actually be
how i see that these things are
different from channel to channel so
these are the
the different channels right here but
how
different are they from input to input
like has the model just kind of learned
a general sequence of attention maps
for all possible input images like that
it works well
because it's pretty it's kind of
suspicious right
that these maps they seem
like so my question would be how much do
these attention maps
really depend on the input
versus how much are they just general
attention
maps right then and um
so i can totally see that this model
might
just do all the work in the latent
transformer
by simply having so many layers and that
the attention
isn't too important like it would always
do
the same sort of attention no matter
what the input is and
i can see a model like that totally uh
performing
well so in order for me to demonstrate
that this idea really works as
advertised namely that you know the
model selects itself what it wants to
attend to iteratively informed by the
data and so on
uh it would be cool to see that these
things somehow depend on the data
because this grid pattern right now
tells me that maybe they don't
okay so the last thing they also applied
is as i said to audio video
3d point clouds and i think they
outperform
other methods in these so they reach
state of the art in a bunch of them
which you know pretty pretty cool uh
of course image computer vision has been
sort of the prime
or one of the prime disciplines of um
of deep learning research so that's
maybe a bit more competitive
last thing i want to show here is the
ablations
so they find specifically that you know
the number of latent variables which is
the
you know the size of the q the
the the n so that this is what we need
to keep small
in order to avoid this quadratic
bottleneck you can
pretty clearly see that as this goes up
performance goes up so this at least
validates
you know our intuition that if we could
do bigger transformers
it probably would be a good idea
number of attends i think that is
how many times the how many times the
image
goes into the structure
also here the more the better and number
of transformers
per attempt that's you know how many
in-between
self-attention layers do you have uh per
time
you attend the image so that gives your
model time to process and time to decide
what to attend to next time also here
we see we see a rise though
it would be interesting to see like an
interaction term between
uh between these two things um
that will tell us if it's just about
making the model deeper
or or not
okay so that was all i had to say you
can uh
kind of check out the attention maps
they have here
themselves they have them for audio they
have them uh here
i think for the video and also there are
a bunch of experimental details that are
also pretty cool
however i just think it's a cool idea
and i'm excited to
see where people take this all right
that was it from me
i'll see you next time bye